you need to understand that one side is
driven by you killed my family you raped
my daughter and the other side is driven
by you're so evil that were justified in
killing your family anding your
daughters there can be no truce just the
UN just what out to calling for peace no
no no no no no that's not going to
happen Israel has the right to not do
that right now it's like getting it's
like I just got punched and raped and
now we're about to flip the switch on
the RAC and you go no no no no no give
peace a chance how about give you a
chance yeah how about that so the only
way that you could have a truce
according to the UN meaning all guns
down ceasefire okay would be if Israel
puts down all of their weapons puts down
all of their defense systems because
again you see Hamas saying the very fact
that you have a missile defense system
the Iron Dome is a threat to us and
Israel would have to give up all of this
land and you would have to believe that
if Israel did that tomorrow Hamas would
say we were wrong about the edication of
Jews what do they do they can't just
give the g a strip